Taiwan is known for its street food and there are tons to try out.
They've got sausages, oyster omelettes, stinky tofu,...
...all kinds of crazy treats.
Bubble tea, you've seen it all over the world,...
...but you probably didn't know it was invented here in Taiwan.
So when you come here, you gotta check it out.
It's refreshing and it tastes absolutely amazing.
Taiwan is also home to the world famous soup-filled dumplings...
...made at Din Tai Fung restaurant.
So the way you eat this, is you poke a little hole,...
...you let the juice come out and then you just put it to your mouth.
Taiwanese food is absolutely amazing,...
...and there are so many ways to experience it.
So don't hold back, get in there and check it all out.
Give your taste buds a thrill.